no respect for these Gurkha soldiers
despite the coronavirus crisis but knife
practice is more spaced out than normal
it's one of a range of new measures to
maintain a social distance while still
staying sharp now the Army is preparing
to either lock down on other types of
activity starting with a resumption of
basic training beyond that the army will
only be doing that training that is
essential to maintaining our output to
defend the people and our interests
around the world
we will be making very deliberate and
clear risk assessments on that activity
and making sure that we're looking after
the health of the recruits the health of
the the army in order to do it outlet
and the health of the nation because we
don't be responsible for the spread of
this disease commanders need to resume
certain activity or risk damaging
military strength a tricky balance with
much of the civilian population still
staying home but lessons will be drawn
from elite units like this Gurkha
regiment in Folkston deemed too critical
to lock down these soldiers need to be
able to deploy anywhere in the world at
a moment's notice they can't let the
pandemic stop their training but if you
look the way they patrol need social
distancing anyway even when dealing with
enemy fire even frontline infantrymen
are having to do more work online zoom
becoming the norm for army life as much
as in the civilian world outdoor
training also changing preak evades the
tendency in trainees to get you know
normal classroom sizes like we'd all be
used to in school together we'd call a
platoon but it's about 30 people and
it's sort of economies of scale you can
have three classes going on and they can
then sort of rotate around say three
lessons but that clearly puts a lot of
people all in one place at one time and
increases the rich risk of spread of
kovat so what's tended to happen since
then is that we've downsized the class
sizes to what we call a section 8 people
the Army's adapting to a new rhythm as
it learns to live with coronavirus a
sign perhaps of the easing of the
national lockdown expected soon Deborah
Haynes Sky News Folkston